I'm in here let's see hi
you're filming so she's a mysteriously
dying to be speak families they
pollinate raspberries prepared as
cucumbers an orchard when bees buzz the
flowers are making love having sex
plants are rooted in the ground it's not
a text text you know what I mean you
plants are living in the ground they
can't hug one another nor can they
reproduce children on their own they
need a messenger of love
a bee to attract bees plants produce
sweet nectar the B drinks from one
flower to then flies to the next
carrying the mail pollens fur while
looking for food at pollinates plant
after plant and each plant starts to
bear fruit the bees are in trouble now a
few years ago they started dying to
start bees bees all over the world that
news is full of reports they say it's a
mystery mm-hmm
wouldn't exist without these compliment
fragrant plants are pollinated by
insects playing and dry
unlike bumblebees and butterfly things
remain true to one type of flower some
of these fly only their apples oh
there's only two bell flowers they don't
fly to a different type of no they
finished one of the issues that just
went about trying to turn on think about
Charles and I have been discussing is
this disappearance right and Charlotte
we talked about this the kind of
Caribbean Cambridge is disappeared
because of gentrification right and
we're seeing the same pattern all over
the world
the list is keep it in the United States
for now so I started thinking about the
hive and as a town and this coming
together of us as humans as a little
town a little town meeting so I'm
working on this doo-wop sound to try to
use bits of music events of Sally's back
have brought together before so here I
dance all day to be here for lovers walk
great things when you hear more militant
styles but this is a doo-wop sound I
guess little time this little town
there's no words yet
but
[Music]
I know what
having this conversation
Oh
talk
let's just keep doing this but like but
we are not yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Sharla Braithwaite I'm a director
working on b-boy I also teach here in
the theater department so I'm really
happy to be able to be here with all of
you and then also like the pan the the
group that I'm working on the piece
which is Guillermo Brown who's inside I
think he'll come out in a second they're
soundchecking he's running a little late
so he'll be in is also visual artist is
gonna be doing costumes and installation
eventually when the piece comes to full
fruition but um yeah thank you
the mind frame I guess there's just a
lot of talk around you hear people
talking about Africanized bees and his
bees escape from Brazil you know they
were they were there were men to to be
mixed with European bees right and they
escaped and now they're they're
everywhere they're doing well you know
somehow they're they're more robust
honey the honey is just as
you see what I mean so even before bee
colony collapse we have this like market
and hysteria around the insect world and
and that type of fear you know and then
so I just kind of tried to unpack it and
talking to Charlotte and just I'd looked
at this Pushkin story the folk tale of
the tale of tsar saltan
which is the Opera that rimsky-korsakov
turned into the thing that became the
flight of the bumblebee a boy transforms
himself to go back to send a message to
his father the king that he's okay
basically it's a nutshell that the story
is from a faraway land
he gets grander wished and it transforms
himself into a insect that goes and
stating this to say like oh I'm here I'm
alright things are gonna be okay
so I'd like that image of transformation
and and that's kind of where I began to
like to look at the stuff and I said
well I really need all the really
serious work that I've done as a support
supporting cast member has had a
director and a producer and been well
funded so I just took time to you know
I've worked in New York for so many
years where it's just quick just do it
and it's done and even in even now in my
you know more commercial world it's just
like quick doom get the idea good we're
on the recording and a sudden it's over
and boom you know like song now and I'm
not doing that I said to myself what do
I want to do I want to make a new
instrument how can I incorporate
instrument design invention
so I just I'm taking the time to have
conversations and to research and to
gather data and to figure out what to do
with the data and kind of brainstorm and
falter an experiment around is the piece
and is this an app is this a curriculum
is this all of those things is the
instrument is called B girl now B girl
what is that is that is that something
that is a piece of software or a piece
of hardware or how does it live and
where does it live and is it an
installation is it a performance is an
album is it a video is it a line of
clothing is it a a brand that gets
marketed around issues of violence
against the environment against each
other about covering fear I mean so many
different layers to it then I'm just
taking time that's kind of that's kind
of it and then Charlotte is here and I
think looking for ways to reach out to
the community here I think I don't want
to speak for you but I felt when our
conversations you felt I felt a kind of
isolation and gosh you never feel
isolated that pains me to know that
you've been here feeling that way and
you can take yeah I mean it's so great
when you have an opportunity as an
artist to
theater artists specifically because
theater is about people living now
even if we're telling old stories we're
telling stories that have words to live
by
right and so it needs to stay connected
with the people and so often when you
make theater you're like you know
siphoned off and your little rehearsal
room with your ideas and your crew and
so the opportunity like open up not only
my experience at MIT with all of you
being here but also the experience of
how we are going to make this piece
which is not just like actors on stage
doing a thing it's like larger than that
like so this gives this this residency
has given us an opportunity to like kind
of open that up and so what you're gonna
be seeing tonight is like really early
early super early stages of like here's
an idea here's a smell of something
right here's a little taste
it's like in a moose Boosh of ideas
nothing is like oh this is finished and
this is it so part of you being here and
part of the hope and falesha of you
being here it's not even so much that
you respond on the work but that there
are questions that we have that are kind
of burning inside of us that we want to
open up and hear from you because even
just I mean Brandon welcome I'm going to
give you a second to introduce yourself
as well but it's such an eclectic group
of people who are coming from so many
different points of view and I also
often feel in social justice work in
theater or in performance what happens
is that there's often a focus on the
difficult parts and we know the
difficult parts we're living in the
difficult parts we're hearing about them
every day we're inundated with them but
theater gives us the opportunity or are
the theater I say encompass everybody in
theater writes and music and theater and
language and bodies and all of that but
I feel like it gives me the opportunity
personally to like imagine a world that
is better than right or other
possibilities that transform
[Laughter]
so what I'm interested in is hearing I
want to share some of the quick I'm
gonna let Brandon introduce himself and
then I'm going to share some of the
questions with you now we have a large
panel which is what I really wanted is
to have like a big group of people I
have no idea how many people are coming
to this thing you know it could be 100
it could be just us either way I think
we can still do that work and I'm also
hoping that we can keep talking to you
in future that this is like the
beginning of a relationship you know and
then tea and do great things you know
what I mean my students need to be
people like you and we may email you in
a while and say hey you you mention that
thing can we come back to that and like
talk about that in a more intimate way